c'est l'heure du journal de l'afrique
soyez les bienvenus sur france24 édition
spéciale ce soir consacrée à la
commémoration de l'abolition de
l'esclavagé pour la première fois nous
vous emmènerons dans les antilles nous
verrons comment cette mémoire est
appréhendé et enseigner aux plus jeunes
dans les écoles nous irons également au
bénin à la rencontre de deux antilles et
sur la trace de leur passé enfin nous
aborderons avec notre invité doudou
diène haut fonctionnaire sénégalais
rapporteur pour la fondation pour la
mémoire de l'esclavagé
la question de la transmission de la
mémoire et des passerelles entre
l'afrique et les antilles et les
caraïbes
mais d'abord ces images de la cérémonie
de commémoration elle a eu lieu au
jardin du luxembourg à paris 400 jeunes
venus de toute la france étaient
présents autour d' emmanuel macron le
chef de l'état qui a rendu hommage aux
victimes de l'esclavagé il n'a toutefois
pas pris la parole la cérémonie a été
rythmée par des chants des témoignages
d'élèves de classes venues de métropole
et d'outre-mer un hommage particulier a
été rendu à solitude une ancienne
esclave guadeloupéen qui s'étaient
révoltés et qui fut exécuté en 1802
et justement une fois n'est pas coutume
on va vous emmener dans les antilles
plus précisément dans un collège à
rivière-pilote en martinique la balle
enseignements de cette période
esclavagiste prend une dimension
particulière tant elle concerne les
descendants directs des collégiens elle
n'en est pas moins importante en
métropole mais vous verrez que la
transmission est différente reportage de
martinique la première avec pierre
lacombe et albane lucien à droite le
collège jacques roumain a rivière pilote
en martinique
à gauche le collège antoine de
saint-exupéry à niort dans les deux
sèvres de classe deux approches sur le
thème de l' esclavage
ou les esclaves ils sont récupérés
d'afrique entre 300 et 450 élèves
enfermés dans laquelle il faisait chaud
en martinique terre de mémoire ce
travail est essentiel auprès des jeunes
générations d'abord parce que cette
histoire est la leur et ensuite parce
qu'il convient de ne jamais oublier ce
que ces hommes et ces femmes en temps
durs et il ya une différence entre ce
qu'on leur apprend et la réalité de leur
vie quotidienne les oublie que voilà on
est des terres de mémoire et ce sont des
choses qui ont vraiment eu lieu
vérification des acquis question dans
quelles conditions s'est effectué la
traversée des esclaves de l'afrique vers
les antilles et les esclaves sont
entassés dans laquelle il nous parle
beaucoup des espaces de vie et sont mal
nourris ils jouent pas beaucoup
d'hygiène ils sont considérés comme des
belges des animaux
de l'autre côté de l'atlantique les
élèves de 3e du collège saint-exupéry de
niort sont un atelier l'esclavagé à
travers une émission de radio une pièce
de théâtre ou une poésie un jour
l'histoire le rendra hommage peut-être
dans les livres d'image dans la justice
et le respect après tant de douleur l'
esclavage c'est une période bac il faut
pas l'oublier parce que ça peut ça
existe toujours l'histoire c'est la
mémoire et puis surtout c'est la
construction citoyenne c'est de
l'ouverture d'esprit saint vite qu'on
s'enferme et qu'on aille vers les
extrêmes c'est quelque chose qui est moi
je leur dis faut être ouvert il faut
comprendre le passé pour peut-être aussi
voit autrement le présent
l'enseignement de l'esclavagé de la
traite négrière deux mois encore trop
confidentielle dans les programmes
scolaires surtout dans l'hexagone où
l'appréciation pourrait se résumer en
trois mots peut mieux faire
on l'a vu dans ce reportage que les
collégiens à rivière pilote en
martinique sont très appliqués et
connaissent bien le sujet pourtant
l'enseignement de cette histoire est
très récente elle n'a pas toujours été
une évidence comme nous l'expliquent
notre consoeur de martinique la première
stéphanie octavien
dites-vous que rien que le fait
d'aborder ce sujet aujourd'hui dans
cette émission c'est déjà une grande
avancée la question de l'enseignement en
martinique de l'esclavagé l'histoire de
la colonisation de la traite négrière
peut sembler une évidence mais ça n'est
pas le cas puisque ça ne fait que 22 ans
que ces sujets sont officiellement
inscrits par l'éducation nationale au
programme de nos enfants à l'époque
coloniale il n'était absolument pas
question d'enseigner quoi que ce soit
bien évidemment aux populations noires
libre ou pas un peu plus tard vers 1920
dans les leçons d'histoire les petits
écoliers pouvait lire nos ancêtres les
gaulois imaginez un peu l'aberration
vous n'ignorez pas que les questions
identitaires sont très forte ici chez
nous en martinique il y a eu d'ailleurs
en ce sens plusieurs actions menées par
des activistes on se souvient des
déboulonnage et destruction de statut
lié à notre passé colonial il est
heureux donc aujourd'hui pour nous que
nous n'ayons plus à compter sur les
initiatives individuelles des
enseignants pour parler de notre
histoire à nos enfants maintenant bien
sûr cela reste toujours perfectible dans
un programme national on peut parfois
manquer de temps pour ses adaptations un
local et puis on peut surtout regretter
que l'histoire des outre mer ne soient
pas mieux enseigner dans l'hexagone
et doudounes doudou diène haut
fonctionnaire sénégalais et ancien
rapporteur de l'onu sur le racisme s'est
également rapporteur pour la fondation
pour la mémoire de l'esclavagé vous êtes
notre invité ce soir merci d'être avec
nous pourquoi aura-t-il fallu autant de
temps pour que la mémoire de l'esclavagé
soit enseigné mais parce qu'il faut
rappeler que ce dont nous parlons c'est
ce qu'un historien français jean michel
devaux en historien de notes
appelez-la plus grands tragédie de
l'histoire humaine par sa durée et son
ampleur
12 millions + existera d'êtres humains
peuple et cette tragédie est marqué par
le silence et l'invisibilité le silence
historique des livres d'histoire et la
visibilité des victimes et donc c'est la
raison pour laquelle
christiane taubira a voulu briser ce
silence et cette invisibilité l écueil
de la mise en oeuvre de la loi taubira
c'est précisément l'enseignement c'est à
dire connaître cette tragédie
cette face obscure de l'histoire de la
france et encore maintenant ce silence
perdure en profondeur alors justement on
a entendu notre concert stéphanie
octavia le dire l'histoire des outre mer
n'est pas assez enseignée en france vous
partagez cette année totalement je pense
que même les officiels de l'éducation
nationale française le reconnaissent la
fondation a demandé à ce que cette
dimension de la loi taubira prg est une
réalité c'est à dire que littéralement
l'éducation nationale de l'école
primaire à l'université se saisissent de
cette base centrale de l'histoire
française et jusqu'à maintenant il ya
des résistances extrêmement profonde
alors aussi le lien n'est pas évident
entre l'hexagone et les outre-mer il ne
l'est pas non plus avec l'afrique la
terre d'origine pourtant ils sont de
plus en plus nombreux ces antillais à
reprendre le chemin de l'afrique pour
renouer avec leur passé et leur histoire
reportage à ouidah au bénin de notre
correspondant le manuel sodji
bako est originaire de la guadeloupe le
trentenaire a tout quitté pour
s'installer au bénin il y a trois ans
plusieurs siècles après qu'un de ses
descendants a été déporté du continent
durant la traite négrière
françois gabourg lui vient de la
martinique pour son projet de bande
dessinée l'auteur fait des recherches
sur quelques semaines au bénin sur
l'héritage africain des antillais
stéphane s'est choisi un nom ouest
africain bako bien avant son arrivée sur
le continent depuis
continue son apprentissage en terre
béninoise hors des sentiers battus loin
du tourisme mémoriel
vous êtes chez vous à suivre ce qui
intéresse la frau caribéen c'est cette
école primaire où l'on enseigne à la
fois le programme officiel mais aussi la
culture endogène comme les vertus des
plantes l'art divinatoire appelé ici le
phare pour bako la réparation
identitaire face avant tout par la
reconnexion au vaudou je la vois
aujourd'hui beaucoup plus comme une
science est un mode de vie qui
totalement partie prenante de la culture
en ce sens là que pour moi c'était
important mon objet était de renouer que
les origines de ma culture de pouvoir
renouer lui aussi avec une cette
partition l'école du vaudou c'est
tellement inimaginable
dans martinique et en guadeloupe le
souverain pontife vaudou wendo dabo ou
non deux qui a pris la présence d'
afrodescendants vient à leur rencontre
nous devrons tout faire pour que cela
qui sont parti
involontairement et par force plus se
retrouver
le véritable chance invité deux jours
plus tard à une consultation de voyance
traditionnel françois reste en retrait
bako initié au voodoo haïtien est lui
déjà bien avancé dans l'apprentissage de
la culture traditionnelle
la première association à celle là
pouvoir reprendre le fil la ville a été
coupée de pouvoir reprendre ce dont on
nous a dépossédé en réalité
en déportant
les fidèles du vaudou n'ont jamais
oublié ses africains déportés aux
antilles et aux amériques tous les ans
depuis 1728 il fondit rituel le 10
janvier pour célébrer les ancêtres
déracinés et faire venir leurs
descendants aujourd'hui ils sont une
cinquantaine d'afro caribéen avoir pris
le chemin du retour au bénin
définitivement
de dedienne une cinquantaine on l'a
entendu leurs reportages une
cinquantaine d'afro caribéens ont pris
le chemin du retour vers le bénin
le chiffre paraît dérisoire pour toi les
cils peu de personnes y en a beaucoup
plus abrous benaïssa au canada comme aux
mêmes maux bénins et a eu depuis très
longtemps beaucoup de défauts
redescendant qui sont revenus au bénin
mais ce qu'il faut préciser c'est très
important c'est un fait historique
les africains ne connaissent pas un
profondeur l'esclavagé transatlantique
il n'est pas assez enseigne à l'école
ils connaissent les scabs traditionnels
africains qui existent encore d'une
manière indirecte mais ce sont ceux qui
vivent dans les antilles et les
amériques les terres ou l'estrade à
s'implanter c'est eux qui ont la mémoire
dans leur chair et dans l'eau structures
sociales de l esclavage et donc c'est ça
le l'explication de faux alors justement
on va écouter un extrait d'une interview
le seul pays au sénégal le seul pays sur
le continent à avoir adopté une loi
déclarant la traite des noirs et
l'esclavagé crimes contre l'humanité le
pays compte aussi la célèbre île de
gorée symbole du commerce
transatlantique pourtant au sénégal
comme ailleurs dans la région vous
l'avez dit un la mémoire de la traite
négrière et de l'esclavagé est peu
présente c'est un manque de connaissance
de l'histoire de l'exclavage ce long
combat tour et coordinatrice des
africaines rising un mouvement
panafricain militant pour la paix la
justice et qui travaille justement sur
ces questions un mémorial je vous
propose de l'écouter elle répondait aux
questions de notre correspondante à
dakar sarah sa cour cette mémoire est
lesseps ses preuves et que si peu
enseigner
il y a si peu de lumière
dessus
c'est très souvent
ce qu'ils enseignent se spécialise
dans l'histoire est encore une certaine
histoire qui ont qui ont cette
conscience là aussi ce travail là et il
me
très souvent il y a et à une partie
tronquée
dans cet apprentissage là il y a très
peu on ne va pas en profondeur et dans
les détails de ce qui s'est vraiment de
ce qui s'est vraiment passé
donc il ya un travail bien sûr des
sommes colossales à faire non seulement
pour
bluff ou faire ressurgir les vérités les
enseigner nous les rendre accessibles
à la population
doudou diène on a l'impression que sur
le continent cette histoire ne concerne
pas ceux qui ont il ne concerne que ceux
qui ont été déportés on parle plus de la
colonisation des réparations liées à la
colonisation à la mémoire liées à la
colonisation que celles liées à
l'histoire de l'exclavage pourquoi mais
je crois qu'on en parle de plus en plus
et je rappelle que moi j'ai dirigé un
département l'unesco et vous à voir
l'ancien 1984 à ouidah précisément le
programme de la route de l'esclave pour
revenir sur l'histoire de ces tragédies
et donc les elle commence à être
enseignée mais la question de fond c'est
que il ya deux ans de mémoire il ya la
mémoire historique des faits qui sont
encore occultée qui ne sont pas ces
communes sur lequel de l'escaut travail
les historiens mais ce sont les tests de
l'esclavagé l'impact social économique
et politique dans les sens une société
esclavagiste et c'est là qu'on voit que
ce dont nous parlons n'est pas une
histoire du passé mais c'est
littéralement une histoire qui a
structuré le monde occidental et les
sociétés extincteur et jusqu'à
maintenant les communautés marginalisées
économiquement socialement
culturellement
ce sont les mêmes communautés qui ont
été victimes de l'esclave alors on
entendu tout à leur combat touré dira
qu'il faut que certaines vérités
ressurgissent de quelle vérité par le
tech les laves élite la botte des faits
c'est-à-dire cette immense tragédie
ceux qui en parlent ne le connaissent
pas beaucoup au niveau des médias mais
la vérité c'est également les causes
profondes de l esclavage quelles sont
les valeurs humaines qui ont été à la
base et nous savons que ces voleurs
était commercial c'était économique
c'est une histoire d'exploitation de ce
qu'on appelait les richesses de
nouvelles terres entre guillemets des
amériques et donc la question est de
savoir est ce que ces valeurs là
sont les mêmes que celles qui
actuellement dominent les valeurs du
marché c'est à dire l'économie c'est de
réduire être humain à un pur produit et
à une mécanique de production et donc la
vérité et la mémoire portait sur ça et
les conséquences de tout cela alors il y
a aussi peut-être un tabou sur le
continent africain parce que de nombreux
africains ont participé à la traite est
ce que ce tabou persiste encore
aujourd'hui le tabou
bassiste mais de moins en moins les
sociétés africaines s'en saisisse mais
les sociétés africaines ne vont pas en
profondeur un lion l'escapade
traditionnelles africaines l esclavage
transatlantique et je corrige en fait il
n'ya pas que le sénégal ya aussi la
mauritanie ont adopté cette loi après
celle de christiane taubira et donc il
ya un mouvement extrêmement profonds qui
est en cours et surtout il ya un lien
qui enterre de se faire entre les
africains et les descendants d'esclaves
et descendants d'africains qui
esclavagisés disons qu'ils se trouvent
dans les antilles et les amériques et ça
depuis l'époque coloniale jusqu'à
maintenant et ce lien se renforce en
profondeur justement on a l'impression
qu'ils avaient une rancoeur du côté de
de ces descendants d'esclaves vis-à-vis
de l'afrique qui n'aurait pas empêché
l'esclavagé qui aurait parfois participé
à la traite est ce que cette rancoeur
est toujours présent tout est ce qu elle
se dilue dans le temps en fait c'est un
cas est une construction du silence
ce sont les esclavagistes qui ont écrit
l'histoire de l'esclavagé et dans cette
écriture on a posé des paradigmes que
les responsables de l' esclavage ce que
les royaumes africains traditionnels
c'était l'afrique où existe un escabeau
traditionnel mais c'était l'occident
dans son grand mouvement de sortie de
l'occident qui a littéralement construit
le système triangulaire et esclavagistes
et donc c'est rancoeur elle a été
construite pour littéralement masquer
les causes profondes et les
responsabilités effectivement ça a eu un
impact certains descendants des victimes
de l'esclavagé mais c'est encore tous
les grands intellectuels et écrivain et
penseur des antilles l'ont remis en
question de césaire à fallon et tous
depuis très longtemps et en profondeur
et qu'est-ce qui est qu'est ce qui
pourrait faire aujourd'hui les
passerelles se recrée entre entre les
caraïbes les entier et l'afrique d'avoir
la vérité historique qui s'établira en
est le symbole elle et de la guyane et
celle qu'il a fait et ce que l'unesco
fait avec la route de lestrade ce que la
fondation pour la mémoire de l'esclavagé
intel de faire et ce que aussi beaucoup
de chercheurs et d'intellectuels sont 1
défaite donc ce silence lourd dans
l'enseignement dans la société est en
train d'être remises en question par les
communautés qui ont été victimes de
l'esclavagé et donc nous sommes dans une
phase d'accouchement c'est ce qui fait
que nous sommes actuellement l'europe
dans une crise identitaire profonde
c'est à dire ceux qui ont été victimes
de ce système sont en train de
littéralement de se battre pour que le
seul la réalité identitaire occidental
sans réalité multiculturelle et c'est
cette résistance à la diversité
culturelle en termes d'égalité de 2,2 de
toutes les communautés qui fait
actuellement le lit et le programme des
partis d'extrême droite et de ceux qui
encore littéralement se nourrissent de
ce qui a été le pilier aider aux
logiques de l'esclavagé c'est à dire la
construction du racisme anti noir
c'est-à-dire de légitimer le fait qu'on
vante des êtres humains
définies par le code noir comme des
biens meubles c'est la définition de
l'animal dans le code dans le code civil
et c'est précisément ce qu'ils veulent
faire en sorte qu'on reste dans ce
silence et se lance une tablette remise
en question intellectuellement
socialement et économiquement et
culturellement merci beaucoup d'autres
indienne
d'être venu répondre à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes rapporteur
spécial de l'onu sur le racisme merci
infiniment pour votre expertise merci
aux équipes en régie merci à notre chef
d'édition célia karacena et merci à nos
confrères de outre mer la première
d'avoir participé à cette édition
spéciale restez avec nous l'info
continue sur france 24
[Musique]